a mistrial is declared in the california
case against michael avenatti in this
particular case michael avenatti was
cross-examining a member of the treasury
department and questioning why the
government didn't turn over specific
accounting data to him and his defense
team although those are sort of one in
the same at this point avenatti claimed
that this evidence was exculpatory and
integral to his defense and that it was
wrong for the government to not turn it
over before the trial happened the
government said that this data was
effectively not important whatsoever and
was not exculpatory but the judge agreed
with michael avenatti and declared a
mistrial that does not mean that michael
avenatti is going free it just means
that the government will have to retry
michael avenatti a mistrial doesn't mean
that people go off scot-free it just
means that this trial is declared null
and void and the government has to do it
all over again the judge didn't think
that the government had committed any
wrongdoing but they should have turned
this data over to michael avenatti it
was prejudicial so we're going to have
to do this whole thing over again so i
will see them
in court